public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mounir mahjoubi secrétaire d'état au
numérique est l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec les échos radio classique et
la fp
vous vous êtes engagé très tôt un
derrière emmanuel macron après avoir
oeuvré au parti socialiste pour ségolène
royal et françois hollande on en parlera
bien sûr au cours de cette émission qui
va être rythmée par trois grandes
questions 1 emmanuel macron reste il
d'une france des start up au détriment
des usines
vous répondrez sur ce point à jean
francis pécresse alors que nous
dévoilerons tout à l'heure sur ce thème
un sondage exclusif pour l'épreuve de
vérité un sondage opinionway 2 quel
espace emmanuel macron les styles donc à
ses ministres jérémy marot de la fp vous
interroge war 3 comment relancer la
méritocratie républicaine on va vous
poser la question à vous car vous en est
un bel exemple
cette âme tran huy qui viendra tout à
l'heure évoqué votre parcours mais
d'abord monia majorité une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
rien ne va plus entre emmanuel macron et
françois hollande qui ne supporte plus
les critiques du chef de l'état encore
dimanche soir vous l'avez entendu il a
fustigé le quinquennat précédent une
présidence bavarde at il dit ça vous
gêne pas vous de prononcer le nom de
françois hollande
le précédent président de la république
donc oui françois hollande il a fait des
choses formidables
il a déçu sur certains points
aujourd'hui il a réussi à faire donner
vie à la fondation la france s'engage
moi je suis très heureux de tous les
projets qui portent dans les quartiers
populaires il ira faire avec les jeunes
alors on parle de son bilan la est donc
aujourd'hui à manama qu'on ne prononce
pas son nom comment est ce que vous
expliquez cette forme de dédain je veux
moi je n'analyse pas comme ça peut-être
que dans cette émission il a pas
prononcer son nom
ce qui est important c'est d'expliquer
l'action de notre gouvernement
aujourd'hui et l'action que vous portez
le président de la république pour la
france
il explique ce que nous retenons du
précédent quinquennat ce que nous
retenons des 15 dernières années et ce
qu'on ne veut pas retenir de ce concert
quinquennat ou de ski on veut retenir
comme des choses à ne pas faire part et
d'autre c'était important de pouvoir
faire le bilan mais aujourd'hui je
cherche pas à construire ou un modelé
l'idée d'une relation tendue entre les
deux elle est exécrable à tel point que
d'ailleurs je l'avais plus que ouais
c'est bien les deux ah ah bon elle vous
dit que les relations sont bonnes vous
ben je dis que en tout cas je n'ai pas
l'impression que le succès elles sont
pas très bonnes à tel point qu'en fait
tonne emmanuel macron a de très bonnes
relations avec tous les ex président de
la république encore aujourd'hui par
exemple
valéry giscard d'estaing qui célèbre sa
jeunesse sa vitalité avec tous donc sauf
avec eux
françois hollande a d'ailleurs et
giscard aurait glissé cet été à
l'oreille des manuels macron quel
dommage que vous n'ayez que vous n'ayez
pas eu l'occasion de servir un grand
président est ce que c'est une parole
juste
selon vous c'est déjà une parole
rapporté jeu vous allez même demandé de
commenter une rapport une parole
rapporté alors vous donc vous n'avez
aucun mal à dire que vous avez été
socialiste et que vous avez donc servi à
la fois les campagnes de ségolène royal
et elle est de françois hollande en
milito et
et j'étais avant d'être sous si j'étais
délégué syndical engagé dans le
syndicalisme en entreprise
je vais défendu mais que mes collègues
et j'avais envie de prolonger cet
engagement et je défie le parti
socialiste pendant près de plus de 10
ans ouais et en 2006 j'ai voulu
rejoindre ségolène royal en 2012 j'ai
voulu rejoindre françois hollande au
moment des primaires et j'ai accompagné
la chorale numérique à chacun je le
regrette pas toute petite dernière
question sur ce sujet est ce que
françois hollande doit cesser de
critiquer son successeur comme il l'a
fait encore à séoul et moi j'ai dit
qu'il doit arrêter pour vous je pense
que c'est jamais positif de critiquer
par contre ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que ce que je vois émerger avec la
france s'engage c'est beau et j'espère
que françois ne pourrait y briser toutes
ses énergies
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire la suite de l'épreuve de vérité
avec jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique qui
nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonsoir jean francis michel bonsoir
monnières mahjoubi alors est-ce que
emmanuel macron rêve d'une france des
start up au détriment d'une france des
usines je vais aller jouer évidemment à
un parallèle qu'on peut faire entre ses
déclarations sur gms et la suppression
de l' isf en faveur de ceux qui
investissent en france les pme de
l'économie dite traditionnelle c'est 50
% des emplois les pme de l'économie dite
traditionnelle c'est 80% des emplois en
dehors des métropoles
donc ce qui est le plus important pour
notre gouvernement ce sont ces pme ce
sont ces pme et puis ce sont aussi les
start up qui apporte et qui injecte de
l'innovation qui vont plus vite parfois
mais qui sont beaucoup plus petites
aujourd'hui donc c'est très important et
moi dans mes priorités c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir à la fois une
politique de soutien aux start up où on
a un secteur émergent mais qui
représente pas encore beaucoup d'emplois
mais de plus en plus et qui est une une
annonce de l'avenir qui est une annonce
de notre capacité à nous aussi avoir nos
géants de demain qui une capacité aussi
à nous d'aller loin dans les secteurs de
l'innovation sur l'intelligence
artificielle sur la robotisation c'est
important qu'on maîtrise des
technologies en france
mais le plus grand enjeu immédiat c'est
que nos entreprises de l'économie encore
une fois dites traditionnelles c'est
qu'elle soit encore là dans cinq ans
parce que si nos pme et aujourd'hui il
faut se le dire elles sont un peu en
retard les pme françaises en termes de
transformation numérique on est 16ème au
niveau européen donc ça c'est acceptable
en matière de révolution digitale en
termes de transformation de révolution
numérique il se trouve qu'on est on est
on est en retard
moi donc il faut qu'on se mobilise on
l'a annoncé et je vais l'annoncer lundi
avec bruno le maire et benjamin griveaux
on va lancer une initiative pour la
numérisation des tpe pme
on va nommer un chef d'entreprise qui va
porter ce projet avec nous on le donnera
des landes mais c'est quelqu'un qui a
travaillé et ça ne vous étonnera pas
avec moi quand j'étais j'ai mené ce
projet une première fois au sein du
conseil national du numérique quand
j'étais président la priorité c'était la
transformation numérique dpm est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai rejoint
emmanuel macron et pourquoi est la
raison pour laquelle je les rencontre et
c'est parce qu'ensemble on partager la
conviction que l'enjeu c'est la
transformation numérique des pme notre
enjeu c'est la croissance du monde
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
aujourd'hui pour que ces pme pour que
ces chefs de 2
bon d'entreprises moyennes petites et
moyennes se mettent à la gale à la
numérisation a dit l'utilisation directe
la première c'est de leur parler
normalement la première c'est de pas
trop leur en demander
certes ces entreprises elles
fonctionnent elles ont des salariés
elles ont des clients
la question c'est qu'est ce qu'elle peut
faire de plus pour se préparer et pour
certaines d'entre elles qu'est ce
qu'elles peuvent faire de plus pour se
transformer mais avant de faire
l'innovation avant de créer des nouveaux
produits connectés avant de transformer
sa chaîne de production industrie 4.0
mais juste avant il ya par exemple
vendre plus sur internet vendre plus à
l'export créer plus de valeur grâce au
numérique pour conserver les emplois
pour conserver la valeur sur les télés
conserver l'emploi vous dites mais ce
qu'on est sûr que la révolution digitale
donc que vous voulez effectivement
maintenant transférée aux pme ne va pas
détruire plus d'emplois qu'elle va en
créer mais la question que vous posez
c'est celle de la responsabilité du
politique c'est la gestion du temps la
gestion des rythmes
effectivement il ya un moment notre
économie elle va se transformer puisque
c'est dans cinq ans est-ce que c'est
dans dix ans est-ce que la robotisation
massive c'est pour tout de suite ou dans
dix ans est ce que il ya un moment où
toute la valeur ajoutée créée sera créé
plus tôt par des algorithmes et des
robots et dans ce cas là il faudra
repenser la question de la distribution
de la richesse en tout cas ce que je
voulais section des cinq prochaines
années
on a d'abord des pme à faire évoluer et
peut-être que les cinq années suivantes
on aura repenser ses schémas mais vous
le constater aujourd'hui ces robots
n'ont pas remplacé ses salariés par
contre ils sont en train d'être
construit et pas forcément en france
donc il faut qu'on soit capable de mener
ce moyen terme selon m
et ce court terme urgence qu'on est prêt
en france par exemple pour relever le
défi de l'intelligence artificielle qui
arrivent dans nos entreprises et qui va
prendre la place de certaines fonctions
elle va prendre la place de certaines
fonctions dans certains secteurs elle va
transformer radicalement la façon de
travailler au quotidien
elle va augmenter la capacité des
salariés à prendre des décisions mais
elle va parfois remplacé sur
l'intelligence artificielle notre regard
notre volonté c'est de dire on a rien à
subir on n'est pas là pour subir cette
transformation on est là pour les
choisir et on est là pour les porter
avec nos valeurs il ya des valeurs
numériques à la française et des valeurs
sociales à l'européenne à la française
et des valeurs numériques
ouais vous savez il ya un numérique
ultra libérale
je vous en parlais la protection des
données personnelles par exemple c'est
la protection des données personnelles
un critère le deuxième la traitement des
externalités positives des externalités
négatives
le traitement des externalités positives
qu'est-ce que ça s'appelle quand on met
en place un dispositif numérique on peut
s'en rend compte
exclure par exemple moi j'ai une mission
transformer numériquement l'état en
numérisant 100% des démarches d'ici 2012
une version responsable et à la
française c'est justement de mener
performance et humanité de mais ça veut
dire 2022 g10 2012 par un 2022 et
performances et humanité performant ça
veut dire je vais les mener cette
transformation on aura nos 100 %
démarche mais en même temps je m'occupe
des 13 millions de français qui savent
pas utiliser le numérique
parce que si on s'occupe pas d'eux est
bas alors en fait ça sert à rien de les
numériser nos démarches parce qu'on à 13
millions qui vont pas savoir les
utiliser et qui vont vivre comme une
violence au quotidien
alors voilà pour la politique numérique
on va parler de la politique économique
et de la politique fiscale avec d'abord
ce sondage que je vous ai promis donc
opinionway a posé la question pour
l'épreuve de vérité
cette politique et économique était plus
favorable aux usines co start-up un
petit oui à 15% est elle aussi favorable
aux usines co start-up une majorité de
51 % de oui est elle moins favorable aux
usines co start-up 31 % de oui il y
avait une deuxième question sur la
perception de la réussite économique en
france
diriez-vous qu'en france la réussite
économique est mal vu hélas il y as oui
assez massif 61% non 38%
est ce que vous partagez ce constat
d'abord c'est ce que la réussite
économique elle reste mal vue en france
et est ce que emmanuel macron et vous
même et d'autres vous pouvez modifier
cette vision des choses
moi je vois comment dans une famille on
voit la réussite économique de ces
enfants je vois dans un quartier comme
on voit la réussite économique de ses
voisins comment dans un quartier on a
envie de la réussite économique de ceux
qui grandissent avec nous moi je la
constate pas au quotidien cette jalousie
je la constate pas au quotidien
cette façon de dire qu'elle est mal vu
moi je crois que la question telle
qu'elle est posée elle nous invite aussi
répondre par le cliché puisque on ne
demande pas à nous si on trouve que
c'est mal si vous aviez posé la question
pensez vous que la réussite économique
c'est mal je pense que vous auriez pas
du tout
61 % de oui les gens n'auraient jamais
osé vous dire donc je pense qu'on a un
sujet sur la perception et la réalité
ouais comment définir réussite
économique
la réussite économique mais on les
définit d'une seule manière c'est donner
la capacité aux gens de décider la vie
qu'ils ont voulu pour eux ou leurs
enfants quel que soit leur milieu
d'origine
quel que soit le territoire où il habite
ça c'est la réussite c'est la réussite
économique c'est la réussite familiale
c'est la réussite sociale et celle là je
pense qu'elle est valorisée qu'elle est
souhaitable et que tout le monde la
souhaitent
moi je la vois pas au quotidien cette
personne jalousie est ce que vous
comprenez le débat sur la restitution
des sf au fond à ou 100 ou 1000 plus
fortunées de france
vous qui êtes associé à vous qui utilise
un socialiste est ce que vous est ce que
vous comprenez cette demande de
transparence ou fond sur ce que va
rapporter à celle-ci ou acmil plus
grosses fortunes françaises
là la suppression de l'sf la suppression
de l'sf c'est pas un cadeau à ses
grandes fortunes françaises
moi je suis un entrepreneur et j'ai été
syndicaliste cgt vous avez raison de le
dire
impliqué
de façon importante pour les politiques
ferait cadeau alors c'est quoi c'est
vouloir profondément que l'argent ce
qu'ils l'ont cet argent que cet argent
ne dorment pas mais que cet argent ils
aillent travailler et qu'il aille
produire lui même de la valeur
l'argent quand on en a et je vois très
bien dans la vie quand on en a pas et
quand on a la chance d'en avoir un petit
peu on a le choix de tout sécurisé et de
tout faire pour que surtout il ne se
passe rien mais que l'on sache où il est
ou alors de se dire j'en ai je vais
prendre des risques est en fait en
prenant des risques ce mot prendre des
risques ça veut dire injecter de
l'argent pour recruter des personnes
pour faire des investissements et pour
lancer relancer notre économie c'est ça
la volonté vous voyez bien quand même ce
que vous opposants disent aujourd'hui
vous dit il faut que vous nous apportez
des preuves que ça va que ça que ça va
marcher dire que cette restitution
d'argent ou fond elle va revenir
effectivement dans l'économie française
et dans l'économie active et regarder
oubliez pas que on ne supprime pas des
essais au crest répondre à cette attente
est par exemple stéphane le foll dibel
gouvernement est bien un iphone et noir
ça mais regarder ce qui va se passer on
devait pas durer
il y aura un géologue d'investissement
on a un impôt sur la fortune immobilière
qui continue d'exister
ce qui veut donc dire que tout l'argent
qu'ils n'iraient pas dans l'économie et
continuera à être taxés comme avant et
donc ça c'est l'incitation la plus
absolue c'est de dire que ce que vous
appelez une restitution
c'est surtout une invitation moi je leur
demande de sortir l'art genre de cet
endroit où il dort pour l'injecter dans
nos pme qui en ont besoin pour investir
alors c'est écouter sur ce point alors
sur ce point on a une réaction
effectivement du sénateur socialiste
racheter mal qui reprend à sa façon
l'image l'analogie avec avec la corde et
utiliser partiel de l'état on l'écouté
vous réagissez et si je reprends
l'expression du prêt d'un flic de la
premier de cordée qu'est-ce qui se passe
selon ben on va le racheter du poids
puisque on va leur retirer du pouvoir
d'achat depuis ce qu'on le retire
notamment des appels
si on augmente la cg et puis les
premiers de cordée tout en haut qui sont
devant mais bon on va les alléger
puisque il ya 3 5 milliards par an pour
cette année mais pour s'y posent aux
années dans les joues
alors donc l'image à cette image de
président des super-riches elle est ce
qu'elle va coller à la peau du président
la république nous partons tous tous
sont qu'un peu de travail c'est de nous
enlever le sparadrap appliquer ce qu'on
est en train de faire aujourd'hui sur ça
canalise la tel que l'expliqué fosse
pour une famille populaire pour un
salarié au smic dès 2018 c'est 400 euros
en plus par an de revenus dette nette à
dire des revenus vraiment en argent
euros sur leur compte en banque
à la fin de l'année pour un couple d'ici
2020 c'est près de plus de près de plus
de 2000 euros vous vous rendez compte
que ça c'est une évolution
ça c'est pour ceux qui ont le moins
c'est valoriser et revaloriser l'idée de
de revaloriser la fonction de du travail
dans les familles c'est redonner envie à
tous ceux qui sont privés d'emploi d'or
dans votre ou 20 et de créer toutes les
capacités pour le faire la révolution
sur le chômage et sur la formation
professionnelle
elle n'a qu'une seule fonction c'est
redonner la capacité à ceux qui en sont
éloignés de trouver un emploi d'être
accompagné d'être financé pendant cette
période ça je sais pas comment vous le
définissez moi c'est exactement ce que
je souhaite pour tout ce qui est autour
de moi n'ont pas d'emploi une formation
un accompagnement financier et c'est
pour ça que parfois on peut être
caricaturées quand on regarde que d'un
côté nous notre équilibre entre libéré
et protégé entre performance et humanité
si on ne prend qu'un des côtés on est
forcément dans la caricature et si vous
regardez dans les deux assemblées vous
voyez bien qu'on peut aussi être
caricaturées de l'autre côté alors en ce
moment-même l'assemblée est en train
d'examiner la flat tax c'est à dire le
prélèvement forfaitaire unique à 30% sur
le capital est ce que vous qui
travaillent et qui est au fond le
ministre de ceux qui investissent et qui
prennent des risques en capital est ce
que vous trouvez qu'on n'aurait pas pu
aller un peu plus loin que ce 30 % il ya
d'autres pays d'europe comme l'espagne
l'allemagne où l'idée
dit qu'ils ont des taux de taxation de
l'épargné qui est moins élevé que le
nôtre 26% 23 % l'espagne est ce que c
est ce que c'est suffisant de faire 30 %
écoutez je pense en tout cas et parce
que j'ai fait des rencontres et de très
nombreux investisseurs et avec de
nombreuses entreprises avant et je
connaissais très bien le système on
avait un système basé sur la décision de
la plus value la taxation de la plus
value sur l'impôt sur le revenu et
l'existence de plus d'une centaine de
niche ce qui fait que tout entrepreneur
qui elle réalise une plus-value devait
prendre un avocat fiscaliste et créer un
schéma qui permettait de profiter de ces
niches est d'optimiser sa plus value ce
qui fait que je vous mets au défi d'être
capable de dire quel était le taux de
prélèvement des plus values sur le
régime précédent puisqu'il y avait des
exceptions absolument partout ce que
fait ce pays fut à 30 foule à 30%
prélèvement forfaitaire unique à 30%
eh ben c'est que quand je mets de
l'argent dans une boîte si jamais ça
marche je sais que la fhp 30%
c'est juste c'est pas beaucoup moins et
ce n'est pas beaucoup et c'est passé pas
plus et c'est pas beaucoup moins
qu'auparavant
sauf que c'est facile de se projeter et
dans l'investissement
une des plus grandes valeurs c'est
d'être capable de se projeter déjà
comprend un très grand risque à investir
dans les boîtes dans ton cas on parle de
start up il ya un taux de défaut très
élevé on parle de pme qui vont faire des
investissements ont dit qu'ils vont
utiliser cet investissement pour
investir des marchés à vis des marchés
de croissance
eh bien il fallait au moins du côté
fiscal on a puisse apporter un peu de
rassurance ouais c'est 30% sur les
investisseurs étrangers avaient deux
choses qui me dit on comprend pas votre
environnement réglementaire lié au
travail pour comprendre votre
environnement réglementaire liée à la
fiscalité
ben là on a simplifié cette lecture est
aujourd'hui les investisseurs on les
voit arriver
merci jean francis deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
jérémy marot de l' agence france presse
qui nous rejoint pour sa question quel
rythme
ah oui un l'épreuve de vérité
cette intense mais vous aimez ça tout
bon soir michel bonsoir
mounir mahjoubi vous êtes donc au
gouvernement secrétaire d'état en charge
du numérique vous allez donc nous livrer
tous les secrets du gouvernement ont
décrit un fonctionnement élyséen assez
centralisé autour d' emmanuel macron qui
est entouré de quelques conseillers
quelle est la marge de manoeuvre pour
vous secrétaire d'état regardez le
travail au quotidien
regardez ce qui est demandé à chacun des
ministres regardez le travail qu'on
réalise avec edouard philippe
regardez le premier exercice qu'on a eu
à faire en arrivant tous ensemble
feuille de route de ce gouvernement
feuille de route de chacun des ministres
on avait un projet qu'on a travaillé
avec les français pendant plus d'un an
c'était le projet présidentiel
c'était le projet législatif on est le
gouvernement qui est chargé de le mettre
en place
on n'a pas le gouvernement chargé de
réinventer un autre projet on est là
pour mettre en place en france tous les
objectifs qui ont été annoncés et
discuter avec les français par le
président de la république pendant toute
la campagne que nous avons menées donc
nous arrivons avec ce programme est avec
nous l'impératif d'expliquer comment on
va le mettre en place
donc moi ma responsabilité au quotidien
ces deux choses 1 c'est de dire comment
je vais faire deux c'est à dire où je
veux aller et menacé de le faire donc on
est arrivé on a dit comment on allait
faire d'eux on a grâce au travail qu'on
avec les administrations oubliez pas qu
une campagne on l'a fait avec des moyens
de bénévoles on est entre nous on se
débrouille là maintenant on est là pour
animer porter diriger l'état donc grâce
aux fonctionnaires nos excellents
fonctionnaires qui ont comme seule
mission de être utiles aux citoyens au
quotidien
maintenant on a une vision plus claire
avec des chiffres qui nous a permis de
faire un premier budget de correction
sur 2010 est d'avoir un budget de vision
sur 2018 2019 2020 barça c'est ce qu'on
a construit les quatre premiers mois et
puis chacun on met nos missions
président de la république il appelle
pas agnès buzyn tous les matins pour
savoir ce qu'elle va faire il appelle
pas mounir mahjoubi pour savoir où j'en
suis sûr la transformation de l'état ou
sur la french tech par contre est-ce que
vous avez pas rendre des comptes
régulièrement c'est un peu aussi sur la
feuille de route initiale coin avait pas
tous les matins alors que tous les
domaines réveille tous les matins je
travaille avec mon cabinet les
directions d'administration et puis on
se demande ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
et comment mais les priorités qui a
besoin de qui
après on se donne rendez-vous le
lendemain le président de la république
on voit le mercredi matin au conseil des
ministres et au conseil des ministres le
président de la république il redonne la
ligne faisant de la république il dit où
on en est aujourd'hui dans le monde où
nous et comment il ressent
l'état de notre économie puis le premier
ministre explique ce que vous faisons
tous ensemble ils donnent le rythme et
puis ensuite chacun quand on est invité
à le faire
on explique on en est individuellement
et comment moment accord avec tous les
autres membres du gouvernement
c'est ça le rythme et la logique en écho
de l'année justement le chef de l'état
expliqué la répartition des rôles un peu
c'est celle que vous aviez ski ça à
l'instant même si il ne parle plus d'une
présidence jupitérienne ya quand même
effectivement la répartition des rôles
telle qu'on la connaît d'ailleurs dans
le quinquennat les décisions
stratégiques sont prises par le
président de la république pourquoi
parce qu'il a reçu le mandat des
françaises et des français
mais les décisions quotidiennes les
arbitrages du quotidien n'est pas vous
qui les rendent et par le premier
ministre conformément à nos institutions
les ministres prennent des décisions et
dirige l'administration ce qui est
essentiel je crois que ce que je vous ai
décrit vrai semble assez fidèlement à ce
que le président vient de vous on va pas
vous mettre en contradiction je parie
que le cheveu et la soirée seront
justement dirige les administrations est
ce que vous dirigez la vôtre on sait que
parfois le choc avec l'administration
quand on est à nouveau ministre un
nouveau secrétaire d'état il est parfois
assez frontal et ben écoutez je les
dirige mais avec la nouvelle méthode de
ce gouvernement et même et les méthodes
qui me souvins personnel c'est à dire
que va dire ben les quatre mais cinq
directeurs d'administrations font partie
de mon équipe c'est à dire que moi j'ai
les cinq membres de mon cabinet puis
j'essaie directeurs des administrations
et j'écris indifféremment des mails
directement avec eux on se réunit une
fois une fois tous les quinze jours
physiquement mais on se réunit
virtuellement avec nos outils très
régulièrement dire que j'ai pas je
convoque jamais mon directeur
illustration dans mon bureau pour lui
dire où en êtes-vous cher gérard rendez
moi un rapport pendant deux mois et on
se voit chaque semaine pour ça
bon sur ce plan a réussi c'est quoi qui
tu manques tu n'as pas réussi à la
recruter on va essayer de lancer une
offre de recrutement à l'extérieur où
est-ce qu'on en est là dessus fais gaffe
je veux conseil télécom
là je veux considérer comme la semaine
prochaine est-ce que nager bien embarqué
toutes vos idées avec ça est ce que tu
peux lui demander lui sur le lancement
de red state diversité si on pouvait pas
mettre avec tester notre équipe et ça a
été la philosophie d'abandonner les
cabines
avec trop de monde quand on a un cabinet
avec 40 personnes
on les rencontre plus les directeurs
d'administration donc en fait on perd
notre capacité à agir immédiatement sur
la réalité parce que ceux qui opèrent au
quotidien nos décisions ceux qui sont
dans la relation avec les citoyens
c'est l'administration et
l'administration ce sont des
fonctionnaires et les fonctionnaires et
les agents publics
ce sont des personnes qui ont dédié leur
vie à être utile aux autres et ben moi
on job c'est travailler que ceux qui
sont utiles aux autres de travailler que
les agents de la fonction publique avec
les agents publics et ça se passe bien
emmanuel macron avait décrit dans son
programme avait promis le spoil system
justement la possibilité de remplacer
dans les six premiers mois de son mandat
les quelques 250 postes je crois qu'ils
étaient nommés en conseil des ministres
skis et ça c'est un changement en
profondeur un changement culturel en
profondeur et ce qu'il faut justement
s'attendre à beaucoup de changements
dans les mois à venir est compris dans
votre administration ce qui est
important dans ce sport dans ce système
dit de spoil system c'est d'avoir la
confiance la plus absolue avec ses
directeurs d'administrations moi je vais
vous raconter comment je travaille avec
eux imaginez si je n'ai pas confiance
avec l'un d'entre vous pourrez pas
avancé aussi vite on pourrait pas aller
aussi loin
donc l'enjeu c'est pas de les remplacer
pour les remplacer c'est de demander à
chacun comment ils voient les choses de
lui rappeler la stratégie donc c'est
pour ça qu'avec le premier à y mettre la
pression en quoi non non non regardez
avec le premier ministre on a chacun
donnait une lettre de mission et on a
travaillé que le premier ministe sur nos
objectifs de l'année de l'année à venir
et de comment on allait mettre en place
le projet présidentiel
cette lettre de mission est de les
transformer en lettres de mission pour
les administrations en expliquant à
celui ci ce que j'attendais de lui
comment on allait dérouler les 4
prochaines années ensemble à celle ci
comment je voulais qu'on me mènent
ensemble et je leur ai demandé de me
dire comment vous voyez les choses
bah il se trouve que moi je suis plutôt
chance aujourd'hui directeur
administration m'ont présenté chacun des
plans sur comment il voulait porter ses
projets et je trouve qu'on les porte
plutôt bien ensemble
mais vous savez ça peut être très
positif aussi quelqu'un qui a porté des
projets depuis huit ans au même endroit
qu'il se dise j'ai envie d'aller porter
ailleurs et c'est bien que vous puissiez
aussi recruté gaga ya pas eu de
guillotine
depuis qu'on est arrivé à pas encore toi
page en dira pas eu de guillotine depuis
qu'on est arrivé alors vous faites
partie des démarcheurs historique on le
rappeler dans la première partie vous
avez rejoint tôt emmanuel macron
comment s'est déroulée au sein du
gouvernement l' amalgame avec les
nouveaux ralliés qui viennent d'ailleurs
plutôt de la droite l'amalgamme là le
travail en commun il s'est construit
parce qu'on avait beaucoup de travail en
commun et moi qui suit ce cadre était
rattaché au premier ministre je
travaille avec chacun d'entre eux tous
là ce sont des personnes qui si elles
ont rejoint ce gouvernement c'est
qu'elle partageait avec nous cette
vision de l'equilibre libéré protéger
performance humanité cette idée qu'il
fallait absolument qu'on crée les
capacités de créer de la valeur dans
notre économie pour être capable de
créer des systèmes de redistribution
juste et avait que ça se passe
particulièrement bien j'ai une
complicité importante avec gérald
darmanin avec qui nous menons action
publique 2022 qui est le grand plan de
transformation de l'action publique avec
un chantier qu'on a lancé le pr vénisse
tous ensemble la semaine dernière je
travaille avec agnès buzyn sur toutes
les transformations sociales numérique
et sociale
je travaille avec un ministre du travail
c'est qui était une ancienne drh chez
moi un ancien délégué syndical
donc on travaille tous les deux sur le
fameux code du travail numérique
on travaille ensemble sur la formation
au numérique avec tous ces nouveaux dont
vous parlez je partage une complicité de
travail très importante
est-ce que j'ai une complicité de
travail et personnel et en plus intime
avec tous ceux avec qui j'ai fait la
campagne oui avec je vais me rendis avec
benjamin griveaux avec christophe
castaner on vient de partager près de
deux ans de notre vie
donc on a aussi une relation
particulière c'est vrai est-ce que vous
avez l'impression d'avoir abandonné
certaines de vos idées en cours de route
depuis deux ans j'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir abandonné aucune de ces idées et
aujourd'hui il ya quand même beaucoup de
critiques qui s'abattent sur le chef de
l'état et qui est présenté comme un
unijambiste par exemple cette semaine
dans l'obs et un président de droite
la galerie ce qu'on a fait sur la taxe
d'habitation regarder ce qu'on est en
train de faire sur la formation
professionnelle
regardez ce qu'on est en train de faire
sur le droit au chômage
regardez ce qu'on apprend de faire dans
la réalité de la vie de la fiche de paye
des salariés pauvres en france
regardez ce qu'on est en train de faire
dans la réalité et la vie des familles
pauvres avec des enfants sous le seuil
de pauvreté
le plan sur la jeunesse pauvre qui est
annoncé par agnès buzyn président de la
république tout ça c'est des mesures
profondément de redistribution sociale
et regardez notre
rend chez ma fiscale que nous sommes en
train de construire d'annoncer avec les
réductions avec la construction on reste
quand même la france et on reste quand
même au sein de l'europe
le pacte social européen le pacte social
français c'est d'avoir un niveau de
prélèvements qui reste assez important
tant qu'on aura des sites socialiser le
risque de santé moi je vous annonce
qu'en france on a fait ce choix depuis
longtemps et que ce choix on essaie de
porter fort et ben ça coûte cher de
socialiser le risque de santé sauf qu'en
france c'est un des rares pays au monde
où on n'a pas peur ou alors non on a
peur d'avoir le cancer
sauf qu'on a peur que d'une chose c'est
de vivre et de se battre contre la
maladie on n'a pas peur du côté
financier n'y a pas beaucoup de pays
dans le monde où on peut avoir cette
conviction la et ben ça on ne remet pas
en cause
on est profondément français on est
profondément européen et on croit à cet
équilibre une politique de
redistribution importantes et d'une
politique capable de créer la valeur dit
il c'est paradoxal parce que ces mesures
là que plus social que vous énumérez
auxquels on peut ajouter d'ailleurs la
revalorisation de l'allocation adulte
handicapé par exemple où elle un prix -
l'image le président des riches c'est
celle là qui impriment en ce moment et
ce qui à la nécessité pour un certain
nombre de ministres de porter plus haut
et plus fort l'exigence de justice
sociale à laquelle vous êtes sûrement
très sensible là j'y suis très sensible
c'est le fondement de mon implication
sociale depuis toujours d'étranges et
aider les syndicats c'était dans une
volonté de lutte que je me suis d'abord
engagée puis à prier la sagesse avec
l'âge mais cette lutte elle reste la
question la question fondamentale
effectivement est ce que ceux ci sachent
parler plus vrai au mieux pour qui fait
certainement du gouvernement vous
d'autres on a parlé des ministres issus
de la gauche c'est parce que c'est mieux
il faut qu'on le porte plus fort il faut
qu'on le dise plus régulièrement il faut
qu'on le montre plus régulièrement
et puis l'opposition aujourd'hui elle
nous attaquent plus sur nos mesures qui
seraient considérés comme étant des
mesures libérales économiquement et
moins sur ces mesures là et donc comme
on les attaque moins on en parle moins
c'est à dire on n'a pas une droite qui
nous les reproches on n'a pas une gauche
qui dévalorise donc effectivement l'un
dans l'ain elles sont complètement mises
elles sont pas elles ne sont pas sûrs
valorisé par la chambre d'écho que peut
représenter et les médias et internet et
les illusions du lycée est un parti un
parti un parti justement vous qui avez
créé
partie de ces marcheurs historique
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas désole de
l'absence du parti en ce moment qui a
semble avoir du mal à se structurer à
soutenir justement l'action
gouvernementale ce que vous êtes déjà
venu dans une réunion en marche de local
est ce que vous êtes venu récemment
si vous venez récemment vous verrez
qu'il y a des débats vous verriez que on
retrouve les militants sur les marchés
toutes les semaines vous verrez qu'on a
continué notre travail à parler avec les
personnes a essayé d'expliquer c'était
nous ont été noués ou deux dirigeants un
roman emblématique dans marche
médiatique je vous parle de l'action sur
le net
oui pour porter la parole y a pas que
les marchés il y avait aligné place des
fêtes dimanche avec la fête des morts et
oui il y aura pas de chasse a plu mais
il y aura des militants en marche
donc vous choisissez et ouais je laime
ce parti je vais même ce mouvement et on
est beaucoup à l'aimer aujourd'hui est
ce que ce parti est suffisamment audible
escribano il reconstruire comme les
soldes vie et regardez on est dans un
cycle où on a construit un mouvement
avec peu de monde on a réussi à devenir
plus nombreux
et puis il se trouve qu'on a gagné des
élections ils seront à gagner des
élections au parlement à l'assemblée
nationale il a gagné l'élection
présidentielle gagnée mais dans le coeur
des français a beaucoup de gens qui ont
quitté le parti ou qui ont quitté pas de
coeur mais qui ont été éloignés par
leurs responsabilités moi j'aurais
j'aimerais passer plus de temps au parti
j'aimerais passer plus de temps et on
est beaucoup à vouloir passer plus de
temps et donc aujourd'hui l'enjeu de ce
parti c'est de recruter encore plus de
talent ce qui est plus de personnes qui
viennent parmi les permanents
aujourd'hui vous l'avez noté cette
semaine nous avons maintenant un conseil
qui va permettre d'élire à l'intérieur
un conseil exécutif et au sein de ce
conseil exécutif nous aurons donc un
président laissons le temps venir et
vous allez voir la république en marche
sera une source d'inspiration une source
d'innovation une source d'action et qui
permettra au gouvernement de toujours
avoir un temps d'avancé au parlement de
toujours vers une chambre d'écho et
d'agir au quotidien sur le territoire
merci on connaîtra pas ce soir le nom
des futurs dirigeants à gérer musulmans
dans la caisse noire qui vous souteniez
justement pour devenir
j'attends qu'ils aient des candidats
égal et attend de savoir comment
eros est votre favori je sais pas si
j'ai des favoris mais regarder des gens
formidables pour diriger ce parti y'a
pas à lui il y en a d'autres
ce parti il est avant tout le projet de
tous ceux qui nous ont rejoint ceux qui
étaient là au début ce qui se dira donc
on aura un dirigeant qui valorisera
toutes ces personnes là où une
dirigeants puisque vous semblez
l'exclure on dit simplement que ça
l'urgent est allé on attendra comme vous
merci merci jérémy dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité avec notament tran
huy qui arrive depuis xe et là on va
parler encore de vous waouh saint michel
pour soi mounir majidi
alors on va parler effectivement de
votre parcours vous venez d'une famille
modeste d'origine étrangère donc gina
marocaine et vous avez bien en suit une
scolarité sans faute études de droit
sciences po que l'on gagne puis
l'ascension que l'on voit aujourd'hui
est ce que vous vous considérez comme un
produit réussite de la méritocratie
républicaine
ce qui est certain et vous l'avez
rappelé rade dans le parcours j'ai passé
toute ma vie dans le système public
j'ai bénéficié de tout ce que l'école
peut apporter j'ai eu d'excellents m
j'ai eu d'excellents professeurs j'ai
accédé aux meilleurs musées même
internet je les ai découverts dans un
musée paris la découverte au palais de
la découverte donc toute ma vie je les
fais grâce à ce que l'état jusqu'à ce
que le public peut offrir aux familles
est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas d'être
plutôt une exception qu'une illustration
de la sphère sociale de l'ascenseur
social qui est plutôt en panne en france
on le voit par exemple dans
l'enseignement supérieur il ya 40 % de
boursiers la première année on a plus de
10% master vous avez raison et c'est
pour ça que c'est un combat permanent
c'est à dire qu'on doit jamais se
satisfaire des champions doit jamais se
satisfaire des super héros parce que ce
match me dit j'ai réuni près de 200
femmes du numérique et on va se
retrouver ce soir avec marlène schiappa
et cette semaine j'étais c'est important
pour moi on avait célébré la première
promotion de french tech diversité qui
sont des entrepreneurs du numérique qui
viennent des quartiers populaires ce que
je leur ai dit c'est quand je vois
toutes vos têtes quand je vois tous ici
alors qu'on parle de performance du
numérique je trouve ça formidable parce
que le résultat vous voit pas il ya une
femme sur dix est vrai qu'un
entrepreneur il ya très peu de personnes
issues des quartiers populaires qui est
l'entrepreneur important il ya une
jimmy merveilleuse et c'est pour ça que
il faut se poser la question de pourquoi
cette énergie se ressent pas
entrepreneuriat énergie merveilleuse ya
eu beaucoup d'initiatives où vous êtes
parés de french tech une diversité il ya
eu la jambe france entrepreneurs en 2015
avec françois hollande
et pourtant ça ne prend pas alors ça me
prend pas vous et des autres c'est un
très inégalitaire l'entrepreneuriat des
jo il faut il faut pouvoir se le
permettre de ne pas être salarié quand
exactement et le premier tabou qu'on a
fait tomber avec french tech diversité
ça il ya une règle dans l'investissement
qui vient de la silicon valley et quand
je dis ils viennent façon de faire à la
française et là c'en est une par exemple
ses dires il faut surtout pas qu'avec
les premiers euros on rémunère les
dirigeants et dirigeants il faut qu'ils
rémunèrent du love money il faut que
leurs familles les aides pour le
démarrage et c est quand on était à
certaines banlieues qui est un autre
événement que j'ai soutenu que j'ai
parrainé y avait la présidente du goût
de l'association qui disait nous sommes
famille a beaucoup de love mais ya pas
de monnaie emma avec french etc
diversité les 45000 euros qui sont
injectés dans les boîtes elles
l'utilisent pour investir mais elles ont
aussi le droit de rémunérer les
créateurs puisque renoncer à 600 euros
par mois à 1000 euros par mois alors que
c'est ce qui vous permettrait de payer
juste le loyer est juste un peu votre
part de nourriture et bien cette partie
assez celles qui les empêcherait de
d'entreprendre
alors que compte tenu d'une famille csp
+ où les parents peuvent aider ben là
c'est vrai qu'on s'en fiche de ses 600
euros de démarrages par mois
alors on parle de la méritocratie
républicaine ce n'est pas que
l'entrepreneuriat bien évidemment il ya
les études que l'on peut poursuivre ou
non
alors on a regardé votre parcours vous
avez cité effectivement le palais de la
découverte c'est là que vous avez
commencé à utiliser internet mais vous
avez aussi beaucoup fréquenté je crois
la bibliothèque dans votre quartier dans
le 12e arrondissement c'était vous y
passez tous trois en avril aux îles de
saint-éloi et celle de
de daumesnil voilà c'est ma job is equal
à la règle à camembert
c'est l'invention que j'ai créée pour
gagner le concours de sciences et vie
junior qui est une heure ce qui nous
apparaît que la camembert mais c'était
un test le vrai n'est là à 13 ans
j'étais un peu geek qui est le vrai nom
s'était traceur de diagrammes circulaire
et mesureur dingue express celles qui
ont communiqué pour vous pourtant vous
êtes un très bon communicant est pareil
à l'époque j'étais particulièrement
timide et j'avais une passion pour les
maths alors la timidité vous avez su
laraque ont réécouté un témoignage c'est
celui de votre ami benoît thieulin vous
avez connu très jeune il vous a connu
très jeune mais poursuit quelques
aventures avec lui s'éteint
entrepreneurs du net et à l'instant
géraldine naba boileau l'a rencontré
pour aborder avec avec lui donc votre
itinéraire et puis vos rencontres
décisives là vous n'avez pas été timide
rencontre il a fait rencontre de thomas
hollande il fait la rencontre de
ségolène royal après
bah de macron effectivement à chaque
fois il a su s'imposer convaincre leurs
partiels et qu'il avait du talent qu'il
a est ce qui explique son parcours
quand il est parti de la ségosphère et
qu'on était dans le qg de ségolène royal
il avait montré une vidéo je crois
qu'ils aient un discours de président la
république fût ce qui probablement en
rêve
il ya mahjoubi vous nous feriez un petit
discours présidentiel monia mahjoubi
président ça donne quoi
c'était pas un discours de président
c'était le concours d'éloquence de
sciences po et le concours d'éloquence
de la sorbonne vous avez remporté ces
concours j'ai remporté ce concours et ça
se prépare un beau discours ça doit
venir du coeur ça doit avoir un sens il
faut vouloir transformer son auditoire
il faut avoir envie de lui transmettre
quelque chose
l'un des secrets de votre réussite on a
aussi entendu bonne à turin ce sont les
rencontres à vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure mais il ya ségolène royal
françois hollande thomas hollande
il ya aussi emmanuel macron vous avez su
attirer leur attention vous avez su
saisir ces opportunités
c'est ma seule passion depuis toujours
c'est le numérique j'ai commencé à
travailler à 16 ans parce que ce qu'on
dit pas dans le portrait c'est que de 16
ans à 24 ans j'étais salarié de club
internet je travaille au centre d'appel
tous les samedis tous les dimanches et
donc ça c'est ma vie c'est ma passion
internet programme et être sur les
réseaux et essayer de comprendre comment
ça fonctionne m il ya eu ensuite le
syndicaliste puis la politique est donc
naturellement j'ai tout de suite voulu
sert à ce que le numérique pouvait
apporter à ça donc on est depuis que je
suis sur un terrain depuis que j'ai 16
ans je me pose la question de ce qu'on
peut faire avec internet
la première chose que j'avais fait c'est
un forum de discussion avec les salariés
de club internet puisque je négocie
chaque année les haines à eau avec les
augmente à ninon et dalida m'a
d'ailleurs pour pour eux et club
internet tout à fait gestione là où il
fallait pas que façade puisque après
j'étais même défenseur syndical du pas
du syndicat des ja d'erreurs et donc
j'ai défendu d'autres personnes et j'ai
défendu les droites ses salariés dans
des causes qui était particulièrement
injuste mais vous savez à chaque fois
qu'il a fallu négocier j'ai négocié
chaque fois qu'il a fallu lutter j'ai
lutté et ensuite je suis devenu
entrepreneur et bien moi c'est ça cet
équilibre c'est quand il faut lutter il
faut lutter et il faut aller loin dans
les luttes parce que des choses qui sont
inacceptables
et puis à des moments il faut négocier
parce que la négociation c'est ce qu'ils
apportent
tout de suite des résultats et puis il
ya les entrepreneurs entrepreneuriat
c'est fond c'est aller droit trouver des
choses qui n'existaient pas à proposer
des choses nouvelles
une france qui marche une france où il
ya tout ça à la fois on va continuer à
parler de votre engagement au parti
socialiste avec benoît thieulin vous
vous êtes retrouvé donc dans la
ségosphère en 2007
mais vous avez vite déchanté au parti
socialiste qu'est ce qui s'est passé au
parti socialiste j ai retrouvé tout mon
champ de valeurs serre que sur les idées
je vais pas vous dire que je me suis
sentie est complètement mal et j'étais
un syndicaliste devenu entrepreneur
plutôt social-démocrate donc plutôt
ouverts à la fois à l'idée d'une
économie performante qui permet la
redistribution connaissez déjà cet
équilibre mais au fur et à mesure des
années porter cet équilibre là c'était
être considéré comme étant très à la
droite du parti
donc moi j'ai été assez rapidement
catalogué comme les gens à droite du
parti puisque je croyais très fort et
cette nécessité cas pas la capacité de
l'entrepreneur à créer de la valeur
mais toujours très fort dans cette
redistribution donc catalogué comme ça
avec un mode de fonctionnement que là
j'ai trouvé inacceptable savent que la
vie fond de verre au parti socialiste où
c'est pas un plafond de verre un plafond
de verre ça voudrait dire qu'ils aient
des progressions le parti socialiste est
un parti qui s'était qui s'était tué
lui-même
c'était un parti d'héritage c'est un
parti de malversations pas financière
mais de malversations humaine où on
négocie des postes où ça se passait dans
des coins
c'était toute la vie et tous les clichés
la vieille politique vous pouvez les
véhicules avant notre ambition est
grande
qui était grande tout était dans votre
ambition se heurtaient justement c'est
pas sali mon nom mais je crois que vous
me caricaturer et et je dois perdre une
ambition senoble ces nobles mais parfois
je trouve qu'il ya des caricatures
classiques qui peuvent être faites les
vous avez rastignac
une ambition politique puisque vous avez
essayé par exemple en 2012 d'obtenir une
investiture par exemple alors justement
patrick bloche qui avait investi
négocier mais non c'est pas le bon
vocabulaire
c'est à dire qu'on avait dans ce parti
quand même réussi au bout d'un moment et
mettre en place des procédures
démocratiques
donc c'était un vote des militants est
donc ce qui s'était passé à l'époque
j'ai pas négocier pour avoir une
investiture
j'ai dit que je trouvais inacceptable en
tant que citoyen en tant que socialiste
que à l'époque qu'ils puissent avoir un
seul candidat qui était pas très bien
que c'est patrick bloche met donc vous
rendez compte on allait faire une
élection avec un seul candidat donc
c'est à dire un candidat élu à 99%
moi je fais pas ça est-ce que vous avez
des eaux freiner politiquement dans
votre progression politique au parti
socialiste parce que vous étiez
justement catalogué de droite jeter en
tout cas pas valorisées pour ces valeurs
là par contre il ya des moments où vous
l'aurez remarqué quand j'ai soutenu des
candidats qui selon moi porter cet
équilibre ségolène royal aux primaires
nous avons gagné ces primaires et nous
sommes allés jusqu'au bout avec françois
hollande
je l'accompagnais dès les primaires nous
avons gagné ces primaires nous sommes
allés jusqu'au bout après et au sein de
ce parti il ya un truc qui marchait pas
et c'est pour ça qu'il ait explosé et
c'est pour ça qu'ils de nombreux c'est
quand vous voyez le siège du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui qui est en vente
la petite annonce est passé dans les
échos cela paraît moi je pense aux
salariés je pense à ceux qui n'y soient
les ya des gens qui ont passé des super
moments là-bas ya près d'une centaine de
salariés qui voudrait avoir des moments
pas faciles mais je m'en fous du lieu ce
qui ce qui est compliqué dans ce lieu
c'est les gens qui sont et qui vont
devoir partir
et ouais je pense à eux et puis vous
avez au ministère est juste à côté donc
je passe souvent devant
en tout cas au ps en 2011 vous n'avez
pas l'investiture et puis voilà que cinq
ans plus tard vous êtes le tombeur de
jean christophe cambadélis en marche ça
a été pour vous un formidable
accélérateur de carrière quand même en
tout cas invités
l'espace pour l'acs ce jeune socialiste
pressé il faut arrêter avec les mots
pressé je vis vraiment ça comme une
espèce de de caricatures regardez ce qui
s'est passé dans le 19ème quartiers
populaires je me présente je gagne ce
premier tour assez c'est assez
très en avance et puis un deuxième tour
très serré face à la candidate de la
france insoumise
parce que c'est plutôt une
circonscription très à gauche de couy je
suis très heureux que dans ce quartier
populaire qui est le quartier où
j'habite et ben on ait réussi à faire
partir de ce camp dadis et on a réussi à
faire émerger un véritable débat monia
m'a doublé vous avez aussi été président
du conseil national du numérique
à l'époque on vous a beaucoup entendu
parler du fichier t es un fichier avec
les données personnelles de 60 millions
de français vous demandez absolument sa
suspension
et bien depuis que manuel macro et de
pouvoir s'afficher t es bien il existe
elle est en place vous me demandez plus
sa suspension
alors si vous lisez la longue tribune
que j'ai mise en place et mon audition
auprès du sénat qui est une des éditions
les plus complètes et les plus
intéressantes
le président de la commission des lois à
l'époque avait voulu en faire un
véritable sujet de réflexion et donc
j'avais passé une langue non à long
moment avec cette commission j'ai
surtout demandé sa sécurisation sa
normalisation et j'ai demandé à avoir
cette assurance
ça a été fait et ça a été fait grâce au
travail que le conseil a fait que la
cnil avait fait à l'époque c'est à dire
que quand même à l'époque se fichait
thales avait été mis en place sans que
l'anzhi qui est de l'autorité française
de contrôle des systèmes d'information
pour les protéger et centre la dynamique
l'administration que je dirige
aujourd'hui qui est le grand ingénieur
legrand dsi de l'état ni d'avoir ce ce
fichier donc vous ça faisait quand même
beaucoup de doutes depuis il ya eu un
rapport rendu par chacune une
sécurisation de ce dispositif
donc aujourd'hui moi j'attends toujours
de voir tous les ans où on en est mais
il est sécurisé le monde a consacré un
portrait une page un portrait de vous
récemment c'est un très très beau
portrait et il y avait notamment
mercedes erra qui étaient cités
publicitaire s'élève et qui dit à propos
de vous il a un tigre dans le ventre il
aime charmer séduire mais derrière c'est
une machine à se battre ce n'est pas une
caricature ça
et oui ça s'appelle ambitions est-ce que
je suis un battant
combattant oui sans limite et tout ce
qui entre avec moi l'ont vu est-ce que
je vais me convaincre les personnes j'ai
consacré ma vie à l'éco va donc oui
j'aime convainc et oui j'aime me battre
et vous avez un titre ce que j'ai des
valeurs et s'en vont je me battrai
toujours pour elle je veux plus
d'entrepreneurs je veux qu'on protège
les plus faibles c'est certes nous fait
vivre
merci beaucoup mounir mabrouk merci à
vous merci dame bonne soirée à tous la
semaine prochaine c'est gérard larcher
le président du sénat qui sera notre
invité avec la même énergie
absolument
[Musique]